Vsauce Kevin here at the Metropolitan
Museum of Art in New York City visited
by a record 6.3 million people last year
to look at a rotating collection of over
1.5 million pieces ranging from
Mesopotamian cylinder seals to King
Henry the eighth's personal armor 20% of
the total collection three hundred and
six thousand three hundred and fifty
three items were collected by one person
Jefferson Burdick but why would he do
that why do people collect things
autographs barf bags cards dolls erasers
Faberge eggs gum hair ink Joker's knives
lunchboxes miniature chairs nails oil
perfume bottles quilts rocks soap
toothbrushes umbrella covers video games
wine labels x-men yo-yos Zippos what is
a collection is it just acquiring stuff
or is it a carefully selected curated
assembly around a particular theme is
your memory a collection of thoughts is
living just collecting memories or your
thoughts a collection of you well maybe
but psychoanalyst burger monster burger
defined a collection as the selecting
gathering and keeping of objects of
subjective value Jefferson our verdict
it was cards born in 1900 Burdick grew
up with the dawn of photography and mass
printed illustrations with halftone
printing technology allowing for the
reproduction of complex images picture
cards were inserted into consumer
products like pouches of tobacco to
bolster brand awareness a generation
before television beamed moving pictures
into the living room
Berdych and his friends were captivated
by the brilliantly colored promo
lithographs printed on thin cardboard
stopped saying practically every small
boy saved these
kinds of cards we've made our dads use
certain brands whether they like them or
not the most popular icons - grace
product insert cards came from baseball
a game that took the United States by
storm in the wake of the Civil War by
the 1900's America's cities filled with
teams to play a game that helps unify a
divided country from Boston to st. Louis
regional competition was channeled in
sports
advertisers leveraged the popularity of
the game and its stars to promote their
products in 1889 kids in Boston fought
over the old judge cigarettes picture
card of the Boston Beaneaters like King
Kelly and in 1909 boys in Pittsburgh
watched their fathers open pouches from
the American Tobacco Company to see if
their favorite pirate Horace Wagner
would emerge Wagner who reportedly
didn't want his picture associated with
marketing cigarettes to children pulled
his card from production with fewer than
60 known to exist one of them sold at
auction in 2013 the 2.1 million dollars
but during Burdick's lifetime all of
these cards were basically worthless in
a 1933 Doughty Babe Ruth that could sell
for two hundred and fifty thousand
dollars today is not significantly more
valuable than 1891 Alan and get der
golden penciled Hamburg chicken in 1961
two years before his death verdict
valued that Holy Grail t 206 Wagner card
are just fifty bucks but it wasn't about
the money
it was about the collection he spent a
lifetime amassing not only 30,000
baseball cards but hundreds of thousands
of postcards tobacco and baker cards
ranging from champion women swimmers to
perilous occupations and depictions of
jokes in the developing era of cheap
mass production verdict collected and
catalogued virtually every type of card
printed centuries before the marooned
people of South New Guinea were
collecting human heads
they believed skulls along with other
objects contained a sacred life force
known as mana invisible power capable of
soothing and security anxiety and
feelings of vulnerability mana is the
magic that human belief imbues in
objects whether it's a religious relic
embodying the power of a deity a
dreamcatcher to filter nightmares or
picture cards that can teleport
Jefferson Burdick back to his youth
humans add meaning to objects and search
for solace safety and security in them
which might just come with the territory
of being born Carl Jung the founder of
analytical psychology believed that
collecting stems from a collective
unconscious nuts and berries behavior
inherited from our hunter-gatherer
ancestors father of psychoanalysis
Sigmund Freud believes that collecting
originates in an infant's trauma
associated with bowel control holding on
to one's poop that becomes holding on to
one's objects burner monster burger the
author of collecting and unruly passion
believed collecting to be a relief from
the shocking uncertainty felt when an
infant realizes they're a separate
entity from their mother they're alone
and an object helps fill that void
psychoanalyst Donald Winnicott describes
our comfort object as something that
substitutes the mother-child bond often
a physical object like a teddy bear or
security blanket it's the first
possession of the child that's
understood to be not the mother and not
me
like thumb-sucking replacing the comfort
of breastfeeding the teddy bear becomes
a source of emotional security
collecting is when this protection
becomes a passion but being a collector
requires access to and the availability
of objects historically only the elite
had access bishops like Abbot Suchet
collected religious relics such as
splinters allegedly taken from the Holy
Cross alchemists during the reign of
Rudolf ii gathered artifacts from around
the world with the hopes that somewhere
within the collection why the
Philosopher's Stone
believed to be capable of teaching
humanity the alphabet of creation and
Tsar Peter the Great earned an inherited
cabinet of curiosities furniture
designed to store magical objects like
bees oars and unicorn horns which were
actually narwhal tusks into a collection
spanning 30 rooms that was eventually
opened to the public in 1714 the
availability of items to collect
blossoms during colonization and the
expansion of trade a generation before
Burdick Sir Thomas Phillips set out to
collect one copy of every book in the
world but it wasn't until mass
production that a set could reasonably
be completed you couldn't exactly
collect a complete set of Greek
sculptures Berdych lived in the first
era in which an average person could
build an extensive collection of goods
and many lost control of his hands by
age 33 chronic arthritis likely
exacerbated from his job assembling
electrical parts reduced verdicts
mobility living alone in Syracuse New
York he renewed his childhood interest
in cards made his mission to collect
every single one before he died and he
did it the hard way
Burdick's collection was built by
trading with collectors he met through
magazines and by going to libraries
small store exhibits and
sailes unfortunately for him eBay which
today has over 800 million items listed
and boasts 82 billion dollars worth of
items sold in 2015 was 60 years away
with Burdick as with any true collector
there was no saturation point just as
eating food provides temporary hunger
fulfillment so does obtaining a new
object collector Paul walrus said he
would Marche of X as you eat with his
eyes a sentiment Burdick shared when he
said card collecting is primarily an
inherited love of pictures the hunt to
obtain a new object sparks a collectors
seeking system defined by neuroscientist
dr. yang concept as a basic impulse in
animals including humans to search
investigate and make sense of the
environment it's the same biological
need that drives a dog to investigate a
noise or the curiosity that influenced
you to watch this video for a collector
a satisfaction from attaining a new
piece quickly subsides and the hunt
resumes collecting as a form of
preserving the past confirms our belief
that there must be an infinite truth
life existed before me and will exist
after me and here's the proof collecting
as a form of inspiration influenced
artists like Rembrandt who made
paintings of his antique sculptures of
Homer Aristotle and Socrates or writer
Umberto Eco who when asked if he had
time to read his huge collection of
literature and poetry said it is not
indispensable to read a book it's enough
to touch it and by a mysterious fluid
you absorb it whether its echoes
mysterious fluid or a tribal belief that
objects carry mana
it's the reason an x-ray of Elvis
Presley can sell for $3500 and an x-ray
of your cousin Larry was probably thrown
away and collecting as a form of
establishing one's identity is a
celebration of individuality because no
two collections are the same your button
coin or card collection creates a
conceptual circle of magic that warns
off uncertainty and chaos helps define
you and proves not only that you exist
but that you are unique a collection is
the secure micro world of order entirely
controlled by you in a macro world of
chaos but that becomes a problem in the
toy trains control the conductor in 2013
hoarding disorder was split off into its
own entry under obsessive-compulsive and
related disorders dsm-5 it's defined as
persistent difficulty discarding or
parting with possessions regardless of
the value others may attribute to them
the American Psychiatric Association
estimates that 2 to 5% of the population
suffer from hoarding disorder which
creates fire hazards and health hazards
for themselves and family members some
people are incapable of letting their
objects go but as Burdick's health
deteriorated letting go of his
collection became a personal crusade
when Sir Hahn Sloane donated his massive
collection of coins books and dried
plants to the Royal Society in 1759 the
British Museum was born Jefferson
Burdick was determined to leave his
legacy at the Met and curator a Hyatt
Mayor accepted the offer under the
condition that Burdick organized it all
he spent the next 16 years cataloging
all 300,000 cards and eventually moved
to New York City to work on the project
full-time in a small oak desk here in
the drawings and prints Department of
the met along the way he developed the
American card catalog a classification
system for organizing old cards that
still use today
Berdych was determined to immortalize
his collection in the face of his
progressing illness became a race
against time
he took cortisone shots that made him
sick just a briefly dull pain so bad
that it took a full minute of agony just
to put on his hat he'd often tell mayor
I might not make it
but he did
when the final card was glued down into
history
he stood up painfully twisted into his
coat and said I shan't be back the very
next day Jefferson Burdick checked into
University Hospital and never checked
out he died two months later according
to mayor the cause of his death was an
exhausted heart but he didn't die from
collecting he lived from it and in his
collection lived the dream that a nobody
like Jefferson Burdick a nobody like me
a nobody like you each in our own unique
way has a chance to leave a lasting
positive mark on the world and as always
thanks for watching
you
you
you
huge thanks to Guinness World Records
for providing great photos of amazing
collectors and tremendous thanks to the
Metropolitan Museum of Art and everyone
in the drawings and prints department